(energetic music)
- Hi, my name is Molly,
I live in Los Angeles.
This is my apartment,
I pay $1,400 a month.
Come inside, I'll show you around.
(energetic music)
- Hi, my name is Kaila.
I live just outside of downtown Atlanta
in a two bedroom, two bath
apartment for about $1,400.
Let's go check it out.
(energetic music)
All right, so this is my apartment.
First, we're gonna start with the kitchen.
I would say my style is more so creative.
I hate white walls with a passion.
I'm like, "Why not decorate
and love the place you live?"
This is my clock wall.
One time I went to like Z Gallerie,
and they had this nice clock wall
that was just flooded with clocks.
And so, I kind of stole
the idea from there.
And I just got these from
like different stores.
And I just placed them here.
This is my amenities, I have a dishwasher.
Thank God, because I hate washing dishes.
A fridge, my stove, a ton
of, ton of cabinet space.
Thank God because they are flooded
with food and cooking oil
and all these other type of things.
- This is my kitchen, it
doesn't have a lot to it.
There's no dishwasher,
it's got everything I need.
I tried to like dress it
up, I added more wallpaper.
And it didn't come with a pantry,
so we built this ourselves.
(energetic music)
Oh, cool, right?
- So, this is my dining room here.
I love it, but also, hate it.
I love these three pictures here.
But I feel like I just
rushed and bought them
because I couldn't find anything
else to throw on the wall.
I like 'em, they're okay.
But I feel like they would be better
in like a kid's room, you know?
These little baby animals.
This is my dining room table.
I got it off Craigslist for about $50.
I kind of want a new one,
but it definitely does the trick for now.
And seats about four, and then,
I pull my two decorator chairs over,
and then, it'll seat about six people.
(energetic music)
- Okay, so this is my living room.
Any time I go to like a
flea market or anything,
I buy find like the one gold thing,
and I buy it, and I'm obsessed with it.
So, send gold things my way.
The best part is is I can
do whatever I want to it.
My landlord doesn't care.
So, we put up wallpaper, removable.
We painted the wall.
What we love to do in
here is watch a lot of TV,
and we lay on our giant couch.
My wife likes to drink,
so we have a bar cart.
Wine, TV, cheese plate.
My dog threw up.
(beeps)
- So, this is my living room over here.
When I first moved in,
the walls were white.
And I was just like, "Ah."
I painted the walls blue.
It took about a day and
a half to paint the walls
because I didn't have
like the right tools.
So, there was paint on the ceiling,
there was paint on the carpet,
there was just paint everywhere.
The wall here was just literally
like a brain explosion.
It's just like, "I wanna put this up.
"No, I wanna put this up,
no, I wanna put this up."
So, I was like, "I'm just
gonna put it all up, whatever."
- So, the best part is
this giant terrace we have.
It's huge, we have a full couch out here.
And we have a grill, table.
It's really nice 'cause
LA's got the best weather.
- So, this patio is probably my least
favorite part about the apartment.
Just because it's a little small.
But I mean, it's still okay.
As you can see, there's
nothing really out here.
But it does have a nice view.
At night, it just lights
up, and there's buildings.
They just light up everywhere over there.
And it's actually quite nice.
This is my closet.
As you can see, I have
way too many clothes.
I have way too many
bags, way too many shoes.
This closet is big, but it's
just not big enough for me.
This is my bathroom.
And you can get to it
straight from the closet.
The color scheme is kind of
like not really existent,
but I put blue, there's a
nice little shower curtain.
There's little pops of color everywhere.
You have Marilyn Monroe,
so you just can't go wrong with it.
- Okay, so this is the restroom.
It's kind of small, but
we've added our own shelving.
This is a typical LA bathroom.
And here's our bedroom,
which is a pretty nice size.
It's beautiful, like it
looks out to the Hills.
It's got a huge closet space.
- And this is my bedroom.
This is where the magic
happens, just kidding.
This is where I come and crash every day
after work because I'm exhausted.
These are my two little
nightstands, I love them so much.
One of them, I just use for like jewelry.
So, I just throw all my jewelry over here.
There's not really an
organization to it, but I like it.
Over here, this is my
little cute nightstand.
As you can see, I usually keep
little cute photos of me
and my girlfriend here,
whenever we take these,
we have like a million
of these from everywhere.
This is my guest bedroom.
I just have it done up however,
it's not really decorated.
But no one really sleeps
in here like that,
unless I have like company come over.
Unless I'm charging someone, like,
"Oh, you can stay here for
a month for this price."
Thank God I have a washer and a dryer.
Ours didn't come with it,
but I had to purchase
everything individually.
But it gets the job done.
This is my apartment gym,
it's not the biggest,
but it kind of like gets the jobs done
'cause it has everything you need
to kind of like stay toned,
which I need to work on my arms.
So, this is my pool area,
it's very nice sized and spacious.
It's actually closed today,
which is a good thing
because I'm a degenerate,
and I lost the key to
get in anyway (laughs).
- So, that's what $1,400
can get you in Los Angeles.
A spacious living room, a
huge bedroom with a view,
and a spectacular terrace.
- All right, guys.
Well, thanks for checking
out my apartment.
Now you see what $1,400
can get you in Atlanta.
A beautiful kitchen space,
two bedrooms that are equally
as spacious, a gym, a pool,
everything you could ever imagine.
- Thanks for coming, come
on, come on, get out.
Bye, bye, bye, bye.
Thank you, bye.
- Thanks for joining, now
you gotta go, bye bye.
Holla!
(energetic music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now you're part.
- Subscribe here.
- That was my part.